[Music]
may is with us may is in portland oregon
hi may welcome the ramsay show
hello guys thanks for taking my call
sure um
so i am 20 years old as well as my
boyfriend and we have no debt
we have two vehicles that we paid cash
for and we are currently living at his
parents house
we also have our emergency fund done and
our four months emergency fund for the
bills that we do have
and we are currently saving for either a
house or down payment we are wanting to
get married and we also want a bigger
truck i have horses and
we need a bigger truck to
pull the horse trailer and whatnot so we
are just wondering what to do next
because all of them kind of are
a large amount of money
and we can't buy a house with no credit
and so we're kind of just kind of lost
in life
so your next goal you said is to get
married
yeah we want to get married and we are
living at his parents house so we were
wanting to get a house we wouldn't like
to rent just because we
feel it's kind of a waste of money we
want to invest in a house
so based on what you're saying it sounds
like you guys have already combined
finances what's going on there
um we actually do not combine finances
sorry if that was confusing so you have
separate emergency funds and separate
accounts and separate savings and all
that
yes we do okay
well for sure i pay cash with my vehicle
he's paying cash with his vehicle
he has his four month savings i have my
four months saving we both have our
emergency fund but he's just at work so
i'm kind of calling for both of us and
the future kind of involves both of our
incomes if we were to get married so
so well
number one let me tell you do not buy a
house
with someone you're not married to
under any circumstances
because you're going to get yourself
into a mess
uh if this doesn't work out
the breakup is harder to do than a
divorce is and um you know it's very
difficult to get out because you know he
just decides to leave you got the house
it's in your name it's in his name and
uh or you want to leave you can't leave
because you've got a house
and a mortgage and you're stuck in the
thing so do not buy a house prior to
marriage
under any circumstances and don't buy
any asset of any kind or combine
accounts prior to marriage just because
of that so let me tell you what i what
i've run into 30 years of doing this may
this is why okay there's all these worst
case scenarios but there's also stuff
that's not quite this ugly but here's an
extreme one okay a couple gets engaged
they go buy a house together he gets
killed in a car wreck
now she owns a house with his mother
because he didn't have a will
you see how messy this gets
this is a mess
however if you were married now she owns
a house
instantly changes
if you're married you're going to get
the house
and you know without a will even and so
with a will you know it's a problem so i
would tell you you're 20 years old
you've got plenty of time to buy a house
you guys get married go get you a rental
property pay or go get you a place to
rent inexpensive pile up cash get the
truck pay cash for it
do some stuff start piling up cash for a
good down payment if it takes you two or
three years you're 23 years old you buy
a house you're not gonna die
well i guess he has one because it's
more of his goal to get the truck but
he has like a checklist of a thousand
dollars on a line and every time he gets
a thousand he puts it away okay so we
are our goal is to put you know or his
goal is to pay cash for his truck that
would be the only way he should buy one
yeah that's yep we've been listening to
you for quite a while and we've paid
cash for both four vehicles and they're
both nice so that was kind of
rewarding my kids are ten my youngest is
10 years older than you
all right
so here's what i would tell you if you
were if you were my kid
i would say go get married tomorrow and
go get you a rental property by the end
of the week
move in a rental and start your life
quit trying to play house under daddy's
roof
it's a it's a mess
that's what i would tell you but you
called the old guy and asked him and
you're gonna get the old god dad joke
right so i'm sorry but that's dave's a
boomer yeah dadgum right i
actually am technically a boomer so if
boomer uh the baby boomers are an actual
demographic like millennials it's like
you're a millennial it's like you're
calling somebody a name or something
he's a boomer i feel like only you can
call yourself old david it's a term of
derision yeah yeah but i'm
hey i'm comfortable with it i like it i
like it
this
is the ramsay show